Les ruines
qui n'a jamais ressenti face à elles ce sentiment si romantique de méditation face aux temps anciens ?
Comme une vision d'époques qu'on croit pouvoir effleurer du doigt et pourtant éloignées de nous par un abîme considérable.
Que ressent-on alors lorsqu'on se retrouve non pas devant des ruines mais devant une ville entière
sortie tout droit des entrailles du passé et présentant l'antiquité dans toute sa nudité ?
Tel est le cas de Pompéi.
Cette ville engloutie en
79 après Jésus-Christ sous les nuages de cendres vomis par le Vésuve ne représente-t-elle pas le plus grand vertige qu'on puisse ressentir face aux
civilisations qui nous ont précédés ?
Depuis sa redécouverte la ville romaine suscite de nombreux fantasmes, avides que nous sommes de toucher du doigt les fantômes de Pompéi,
fragments d'hommes, de pierre, portant avec eux l'âme ressuscitée de toute une époque.
Mais ce qui est intéressant avec Pompéi - et surtout en raison du caractère exceptionnel de sa redécouverte -
c'est que la ville a alimenté l'imaginaire de nombreux artistes et bien sûr d'écrivains.
Or si on peut constater que la ville influence les écrivains, il faut surtout insister sur le fait que ces auteurs ont grandement contribué
à projeter sur ces lieux des rêves, des fantasmes, repeuplant finalement toute la ville par le travail d'écriture.
Pompéi en effet est un défi pour l'imagination des artistes,
une ville figée dans la pierre à cause d'une catastrophe unique et qui présente le paradoxe suivant : nous accédons en effet à des morceaux d'antiquités
encore chauds, à des ruines qui pourtant frappent par leur silence puisque les habitants ont désormais disparu depuis très longtemps.
Ce que je vous propose dans cet épisode c'est donc d'étudier dans le détail les représentations artistiques de Pompéi, principalement ses représentations littéraires.
Comment cette cité miraculeusement redécouverte est-elle devenue un objet de fantasme artistique,
sorte de page blanche sur laquelle les écrivains ont projeté des méditations, des rêves ou encore des images ?
Mais pour explorer toute cette histoire je ne serai pas seul : Clothilde de la chaîne Passé Sauvage - qui parle principalement d'archéologie et d'anthropologie -
m'accompagnera tout au long de cet épisode pour essayer d'analyser ce phénomène si complexe qu'est la méditation sur les ruines.
Car finalement la question est bien celle-ci : comment l'art et l'écriture peuvent faire parler les pierres qui semblent vouées à être muettes?
[Générique]
[Musique style antique]
En 79 après Jésus-Christ le Vésuve, fier volcan s'élevant en Italie, dans la région de Campanie, entre en éruption et entraîne
l'ensevelissement de plusieurs cités romaines comme Pompéi mais aussi Herculanum, Stabie ou Oplontis.
L'événement est d'une importance considérable même si la région était connue pour sa grande instabilité.
Cette éruption est d'autant plus terrible qu'elle cause la destruction d'une ville pourtant agréable aux romains, Pompéi étant une ville riche
opulente et accueillant de riches familles.
Si vous voulez plus d'informations sur la ville de Pompéi, je vous conseille vivement d'aller voir la vidéo de Passé Sauvage qui lui est consacrée où
elle parle de l'histoire de la ville et retrace le rôle qu'elle a pu jouer.
En 79 donc le Vésuve entre en éruption
mais par chance nous avons pu conserver les témoignages des écrivains sur ces événements. De cette manière l'éruption du Vésuve entre doublement dans l'histoire :
non seulement dans l'histoire humaine par la redécouverte qui sera faite, mais aussi dans l'histoire littéraire
puisque un auteur très célèbre y perdra la vie, et un auteur qui a beaucoup compté: il s'agit de Pline l'Ancien.
Pline l'Ancien était un naturaliste, un des grands esprits de son temps dont l'oeuvre est incroyable pour nous puisqu'il a rédigé un ouvrage
considérable encore très célèbre aujourd'hui : l'Histoire Naturelle, une somme énorme de toutes les connaissances qu'il avait à disposition.
Inutile vous dire combien cet ouvrage est précieux pour rentrer dans la mentalité de l'antiquité.
Or quand le Vésuve entre en éruption,
Pline l'Ancien se trouve à Misène et observe de loin le panache de fumée qui s'élève du volcan.
C'est par goût pour l'observation scientifique selon les témoignages que Pline décide de se rendre sur place pour prendre des notes et comprendre le phénomène.
Tandis que tout le monde s'enfuit, Pline lui s'approche de la catastrophe. Il y meurt finalement
vraisemblablement asphyxié sur la plage. Mort pour la science en quelque sorte.
Comment avons-nous réussi à savoir ces événements? Deux lettres écrites par son neveu, Pline le Jeune,
relatent dans le détail ces épisodes.
Pline le Jeune les adressent au célèbre historien Tacite.
Il y évoque plusieurs détails techniques, comme la mort de son oncle,
mais aussi la fuite des habitants et les nombreux tremblements de terre.
La description précise qu'il fait du panache de fumée
a permis par la suite de comprendre quelle fut l'éruption du Vésuve.
Une éruption explosive
faite de fumée asphyxiante se déversant sur les flancs du volcan.
Pour la petite histoire, c'est par ces deux lettres
et par Pline l'Ancien et Pline le Jeune
qu'on a renommé ce type d'éruptions volcaniques.
En effet, on appelle désormais éruption plinienne ce type d'explosion
faisant jaillir de grandes quantités de fragments rocheux et créant
de volumineuses colonnes de cendres appelées "colonnes pliniennes"
comme le montrent ces images du Mont Sainte Hélène aux États-Unis en 1980.
[Bruit d'explosion et d'orage]
Ainsi ce type d'éruption possède un nom qui s'inspire de la description qu'en a faite Pline le Jeune
mais c'est aussi une manière de rendre
hommage à Pline l'ancien à cause de l'éruption qui l'a tué.
Immédiatement l'éruption du Vésuve à un très grand écho dans tout l'empire romain,
on s'en effraie,
et les auteurs ressentent le besoin d'écrire sur des événements aussi tragiques.
C'est notamment le cas du poète latin Stace dont la réaction est très intéressante.
En effet, il évoque le fait que plusieurs villes aient été englouties
et plus intéressant encore, il se demande si les populations futures
auront conscience de leur existence.
Belle prédiction de sa part quand on sait que Pompéi et les autres villes qui sont autour
attendront près de quinze siècles avant d'être redécouvertes.
L'événement effraie tellement les romains qu'un autre poète latin, Martial, ressent lui aussi le besoin d'évoquer l'éruption.
Il écrit alors un petit poème commémoratif
au sein de ce qu'on nomme ses Épigrammes
un poème dans lequel il dépeint l'ampleur de la catastrophe
car le Vésuve a abattu la mort sur des terres magnifiques et fertiles.
Dès les premiers écrits Pompéi est donc une cité qui apparaît sous le signe de la catastrophe
ayant presque subi un châtiment divin
et provoquant en fait un effet de sidération devant la violence de tels phénomènes.
Et pourtant, malgré ces témoignages, la cité tombe dans l'oubli très peu de temps après l'éruption.
Peu à peu les villes sont englouties, elles sont abandonnées et subissent de nombreux pillages.
Pompéi est même partiellement démontée, les pierres servant à construire d'autres bâtiments ailleurs,
ce qui se faisait très souvent avant que n'apparaisse le respect récent que nous pratiquons pour les ruines aujourd'hui.
La ville sommeille alors pendant plus d'un millénaire et demi,
gardant sagement ses trésors d'antiquité.
[Musique entraînante]
C'est alors qu'au cours du 18e siècle les villes enfouies par l'éruption sont peu à peu redécouvertes.
Pompéi, en quelque sorte, renaît de ses cendres.
C'est l'époque où le mythe autour de cette ville se développe et ce très rapidement.
En même temps, mettez-vous un peu à la place d'une personne au 18e siècle,
la plupart des lettrés connaissaient sur le bout des doigts
l'antiquité ou encore le latin ;
depuis des siècles l'art et la pensée se sont construits et se sont même structurés
à travers des références antiques ou encore des livres ;
et du jour au lendemain on découvre presque par hasard des villes entières
pétrifiées dans la pierre,
comme une sorte de morceau du passé qu'on leur livrait dans les mains.
ce simple sentiment suffit pour que cette redécouverte passe pour un véritable miracle scientifique
et face au vertige temporel provoqué par un tel événement
le mythe autour de la cité se forme et se forme par étapes.
Tout d'abord de très nombreuses lettres de voyageurs font état de cette redécouverte progressive
L'émerveillement, l'étonnement, la curiosité
sont les moteurs principaux de cette redécouverte perçue comme miraculeuse.
Les premiers écrits dont nous disposons ne sont pourtant pas à l'origine
le fruit d'écrivains à proprement parler.
Pour n'en citer qu'un,
un certain Charles de Brosses, magistrat mais aussi auteur de plusieurs livres,
un passionné d'antiquités,
se rend sur place et s'avère être un des premiers à écrire un témoignage de cette redécouverte.
En novembre 1739, il mentionne longuement la redécouverte d'Herculanum et fait un bilan des fouilles effectuées.
Dans l'ensemble il s'agit d'une description des lieux, des procédés de fouilles
et le brave Charles se plaît considérablement à décrire les objets retrouvés :
des statues, des vases, des meubles,
intérêt qui explique en grande partie comment cette redécouverte de Pompéi
fut principalement profitable aux collectionneurs,
de riches personnes acquérant
- pillant joyeusement pourrait-on même dire -
la ville et ses trésors.
Mais dans son texte il est intéressant de constater qu'il n'y a pas de vraie méditation sur les ruines, sur la mort ou encore sur le temps,
il est peut-être encore trop tôt
Pompéi à cette époque est avant tout un lieu de curiosités et d'antiquités,
en d'autres termes la ville n'a pas encore cette aura magique qu'elle aura par la suite
mais ce n'est qu'une question de temps.
Pendant plus de cinquante ans cette découverte a une diffusion
considérable dans l'ensemble de l'Europe.
Les imaginaires s'affolent devant l'envergure d'un tel événement.
Un véritable tourisme européen débute pour visiter Pompéi,
une véritable mode naît autour de ces ruines avec la venue de nombreuses personnalités vers ces lieux.
Princes, rois, reines se précipitent pour visiter Pompéi.
L'empereur Joseph II d'Autriche effectue sa première visite du site en 1769
où une fouille est mise en scène durant laquelle on exhume des squelettes.
Plus tard François 1er d'Autriche s'y rend en 1819
suivi de la reine victoria en 1838.
Chose plus intéressante, il n'y a pas que des personnalités politiques qui s'y rendent
mais aussi des artistes et des écrivains
lesquels vont être responsables en très grande partie du fait que la ville devienne presque légendaire.
Goethe, le célèbre écrivain allemand, est le premier à s'y rendre.
Chateaubriand le suit de très près, expérience qu'il relate dans son ouvrage Voyage en Italie
où il fait un inventaire des découvertes et admire la vie romaine figée.
En 1811, le poète Lamartine s'y rend également puis c'est le tour de Stendhal en 1817
puis de Nerval en 1834, puis de Flaubert, puis de Théophile Gautier...
Le voyage de tous ces auteurs témoigne de la mode qui s'est créée
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est que la ville à cette époque
devient plus qu'une cité enfouie qu'on aurait redécouverte
elle devient un véritable objet d'art et de méditation.
Pompéi devient une cité fantasmée même s'il existe des écarts importants
entre les auteurs qui n'ont pas tous abordé la ville de la même façon.
De façon assez surprenante les premiers auteurs semblent tout d'abord assez peu enclins
à rêver sur les ruines, montrant un intérêt somme toute assez limité.
C'est assez étrangement le cas de Goethe et de Chateaubriand qui fantasment très peu la ville,
ils se contentent simplement de la décrire minutieusement ou de s'en étonner.
Gustave Flaubert montre guère plus d'enthousiasme
puisque dans ses Voyages en Orient
il se contente juste de décrire
- parfois avec une précision démentielle -
les lieux visités, comme le célèbre amphithéâtre.
Flaubert n'idéalise pas les lieux mais ses interrogations démontrent une chose :
Pompéi est une ville muette, pleine de questions, obligeant ceux qui la visitent
à interpréter les signes qu'elle renvoie.
Pompéi, une sorte de point d'interrogation qui se dresse devant notre regard.
[Musique piano, dramatique]
Face à ce silence, face au temps passé subitement ressuscité,
Pompéi devient très facilement, en dehors de ces quelques textes,
un haut lieu de méditation sur le temps, sur la mort, sur les catastrophes.
Grâce à des tableaux et grâce à plusieurs textes,
Pompéi devient un lieu hautement spirituel et une représentation artistique pour projeter les rêves romantiques.
La redécouverte de Pompéi s'inscrit dans ce courant très fort de l'imaginaire
mélancolique des ruines, un imaginaire qui se développe à la fin du 18e et au début du 19e.
Cet imaginaire a des conséquences sur les pratiques littéraires mais aussi sur l'archéologie
qui est considérée comme une discipline plus que scientifique.
C'est une activité spirituelle,
la fouille du passé, le contact avec la mort,
comme c'est encore bien souvent le cas aujourd'hui d'Indiana Jones à Tomb Raider.
[Musique inquiétante]
Le mythe de Pompéi se forme.
Le premier grand texte romanesque consacré à pompéi apparaît alors en 1834
il s'agit des Derniers jours de Pompéi de Bulwer-Lytton
qui met en scène la vie quotidienne de Pompéi vue à travers le regard du 19e siècle.
Dans ce roman historique,
l'auteur cherche à redonner vie à la cité morte
par la création de personnages
et par la mise en scène d'une relation amoureuse entre le protagoniste Glaucus et une femme dénomée Ione.
L'intrigue du livre est assez complexe, faite de triangles amoureux, de relations déçues ou même de combats religieux,
mais ce qu'on peut dire toutefois c'est que Bulwer-Lytton est un des premiers à avoir ce geste de vouloir faire revivre la ville
par l'art.
La ville chez lui se peuple de fantômes et il est l'un des premiers à la décrire comme, je cite, "la cité des ombres".
Pompéi entre dans l'ère des fantasmes.
Elle devient la ville mélancolique
paradoxale par bien des aspects.
Un texte qui résume à merveille l'image d'une Pompéi idéalisée,
lieu au contact des puissances de la mort,
c'est la très rapide description qu'en fait Mme de Staël dans son roman
Corinne ou l'Italie, en 1807.
Au cours de cette histoire, les personnages effectuent ce voyage en Italie si stéréotypé au 19e siècle,
voyage amoureux qui les conduit dans les ruines de Pompéi.
La description que fait Mme de Staël de la zone est très catastrophique,
les personnages pénètrent dans une sorte de palais des ténèbres, infernales, aux confins de la vie et de la mort.
"Vous entrez dans l'empire de la mort", c'est ce que nous dit le narrateur,
un peu comme si l'on entrait dans l'Enfer de Dante.
Pompéi dans ce texte est surtout l'expérience du temps, une mélancolie face au temps qui passe
et Mme de Staël insiste beaucoup sur l'idée qu'il s'agisse d'une expérience paradoxale.
En déambulant dans les ruines, le voyageur a plus que jamais l'impression de voir la vie romaine en direct
sauf que les maisons ou encore les rues renvoient un silence effrayant.
Toujours est-il que Pompéi, dans ces conditions, stimule l'imagination.
D'ailleurs Mme de Staël voit dans cette ville un défi lancé à l'imagination.
Si la ville offre aux voyageurs l'impression d'un instant d'antiquité figé, elle est surtout pour lui l'occasion de remonter dans le passé.
L'expérience de Pompéi a alors cela d'intéressant qu'elle vient faire se chevaucher les époques
et c'est précisément le thème d'une des nouvelles les plus importantes consacrées à Pompéi
et cette nouvelle s'appelle Arria Marcella, souvenirs de Pompéi de Théophile Gautier.
Théophile Gautier est un des romanciers du 19e siècle connu pour avoir explorer les thématiques du fantastique, des fantômes ou des revenants.
Il se passionne pour l'antiquité et dans les années 1840
cette antiquité dans ses livres devient le foyer de ce que le critique Georges Poulet
a appelé "la rétrospective évocatrice".
Il s'agit en fait selon Gauthier lui même d'une capacité par l'écriture à faire revivre le passé,
à le faire revivre de manière presque magique.
Et c'est l'écrivain, le poète, qui dispose par son art de la capacité à faire revivre le passé en le tirant du néant
où il était plongé.
C'est dans ce contexte que Théophile Gautier s'intéresse à Pompéi
puisque la ville est par définition un morceau de passé
qui a fait irruption dans notre présent.
En 1850, Gauthier voyage alors en Italie et visite Pompéi
ainsi que Naples et son musée.
C'est de ces visites que naît la nouvelle Arria Marcella.
Toute l'intrigue commence par l'admiration du jeune Octavien pour un sein de femme pétrifié, retrouvé à Pompéi
et il tombe, à travers l'image de ce sein, amoureux de la femme à qui il appartenait.
Ce sein est à côté des corps des victimes
l'un des objets les plus prisés des premières fouilles.
Il s'agit en réalité d'une empreinte d'un sein de femme découvert dans les années 1770
dans la villa de Diomède.
Ce fragment a disparu et malgré des opérations de recherches durant les années 50, on ne sait pas ce qu'il est devenu.
La seule hypothèse envisagée serait que ce fragment de sein
se soit totalement désintégré suite aux innombrables tests opérés par les scientifiques du 19e siècle.
Commence alors cette histoire fantastique si surprenante où le protagoniste s'éprend d'un fragment de femme.
Comme le dit Théophile Gautier un "amour rétrospectif" se développe alors,
"rétrospectif", car Octavien tombe amoureux d'une romaine morte depuis des siècles,
cette fameuse Arria Marcella.
Un peu plus tard, alors qu'Octavien se promène de nuit à Pompéi,
la cité reprend vie,
progressivement les ruines redeviennent bâtiment et la vie se peuple alors de fantômes.
C'est dans cette vie fantasmatique qu'il peut dialoguer avec les anciens romains.
Alors que la ville reprend vie,
Octavien cherche alors à retrouver Arria Marcella, ce qu'il réussit à faire.
De manière assez folle, Arria Marcella explique à Octavien qu'elle a réussi
à ressentir l'amour d'Octavien pour elle par delà les siècles
bouleversant notre expérience puisqu'il est sous-entendu qu'Arria Marcella a ressenti l'amour d'Octavien à travers le sein momifié du musée
grâce aux forces magnétiques de l'univers.
Cette histoire un peu perchée s'appuie en fait sur de véritables croyances au 19e siècle
principalement des croyances issues du magnétisme de Mesmer, des théories selon lesquelles il existerait dans l'univers
des forces magnétiques qui régissent la vie entre les êtres ou entre les choses.
L'amour par exemple est alors défini comme une relation d'attraction magnétique entre deux personnes,
une idée qu'on retrouve chez Balzac et dans des expressions encore courantes aujourd'hui
comme le fait que le regard puisse être "magnétique".
Or dans Arria Marcella c'est bien de cet amour magnétique dont il s'agit, avec la croyance philosophique que l'amour dépasse le temps, les époques,
d'où la relation d'Arria Marcella et d'Octavien dans Pompéi.
Cette nouvelle fascinante montre bien comment Pompéi devient le cadre d'une rêverie fantomatique très développée
puisque c'est un lieu où le passé peut reprendre vie.
C'est aussi une bonne manière pour voir comment les auteurs font de ce lieu un endroit hautement mystique.
A côté de tous ces écrits romantiques paraissent des publications scientifiques qui donnent une autre vision du site et des sociétés qui y ont vécu.
Entre 1860 et 1864 paraît
Pompeianarum Antiquitatum Historia, qui retrace l'histoire des fouilles du site.
La découverte de Pompéi et la publication d'écrits scientifiques marquent la naissance de l'archéologie comme science ayant sa méthodologie propre.
On constate aussi avec Nerval ou Gautier combien la ville permet aux deux auteurs d'exprimer des croyances mystiques
de réincarnation, de retour des âmes ou encore de dialogue avec les morts,
le tout en s'appuyant sur des éléments précis de la ville et notamment le fait que sa redécouverte
a donné l'impression que le passé était resté vivant.
On constate aussi combien la représentation de Pompéi s'est complexifiée
devenant une ville fantasmée puis une ville fantasmatique associée aux délires et aux rêves.
[Musique joyeuse]
Mais l'évolution ne va pas s'arrêter là, Pompéi va devenir plus que le théâtre de rêveries :
la ville va symboliser l'inconscient lui-même
et le fonctionnement inconscient de l'esprit humain
grâce à un texte resté célèbre de Sigmund Freud.
Eh oui, il existe bien un texte de Freud qui parle de Pompéi.
A-t-on encore besoin de présenter qui est Sigmund Freud ?
A la fin du 19e siècle et au début du 20e, Freud élabore en détail les théories de l'inconscient.
A travers sa psychanalyse, ainsi que dans ses essais,
il s'est notamment penché sur la question délicate des rêves, de leur signification et de leurs liens avec les mécanismes de l'inconscient.
Parallèlement Freud était un très grand amateur d'archéologie, d'antiquités.
Il visite Pompéi en 1902 puis fait la découverte de la nouvelle de l'auteur allemand Wilhelm Jensen, la Gradiva, en 1903.
Ce texte, dont le sous-titre est "Fantaisie pompéienne",
est alors le sujet d'un livre resté très important dans l'histoire de la pensée et de la littérature :
Délire et rêves dans la Gradiva de Wilhelm Jensen que Freud fait paraître en 1907.
Il s'agit ni plus ni moins que de la première interprétation psychanalytique d'un livre et même d'une oeuvre d'art en général.
Freud cherche en réalité à transposer dans le domaine de l'art des méthodes qu'il utilisait auparavant
notamment pour déceler à l'intérieur des oeuvres des mécanismes inconscients actifs.
Cette oeuvre est cruciale parce qu'elle a ouvert la voie à ce type d'études
- un type d'étude qui est d'ailleurs fortement controversé et c'est un euphémisme -
qui consiste à analyser des textes pour y voir le témoignage par des motifs, des thèmes ou encore des images
d'un fonctionnement inconscient de l'esprit humain.
Comme les plis d'une robe qui révéleraient la forme d'un oiseau et qui seraient une image
inconsciente du peintre.
Il fonde son analyse sur un tableau de Léonard de Vinci, "La Vierge, l'enfant Jésus et Sainte-Anne"
analyse qu'il développe dans un livre : "Un souvenir d'enfance de Léonard de Vinci"
Mais quel rapport avec Pompéi me diriez-vous ?
C'est que le texte que Freud étudie, la Gradiva de Jensen,
raconte dans le même style que Théophile Gautier la découverte par un archéologue nommé Norbert Hanold
d'un bas-relief représentant une femme qui marche
que le protagoniste décide de nommer la Gradiva.
Un peu comme pour Octavien chez Théophile Gautier, Norbert s'éprend de ce tableau et rêve de cette femme.
Il s'imagine qu'elle a vécu à Pompéi et, au cours d'un cauchemar, le protagoniste se l'imagine le 24 août 79
le jour de l'éruption du Vésuve,
mourant asphyxiée.
Convaincu qu'il peut la retrouver il décide alors d'aller directement sur place, à Pompéi, pour retrouver sa trace.
Toute la nouvelle est alors ponctuée de rêves du protagoniste sur Pompéi, sur le Vésuve, sur les ruines et sur la Gradiva.
Ce sont ces rêves qui bien sûr intéresseront Freud.
Petit détail amusant, on sait que Freud décida de se procurer le fameux bas-relief de l'oeuvre qu'il plaça à l'intérieur de son bureau
exactement comme le personnage de la nouvelle.
Plutôt surprenant non?
Freud dans son étude déploie en fait une analogie
parfois un peu bancale et pas tout à fait juste à ses yeux
mais qu'il utilise pourtant
la ville de Pompéi est alors l'image même du refoulement inconscient.
Freud développe son analyse selon laquelle la psychanalyse est comparable à l'archéologie.
De même que l'archéologue explore et fouille les différentes strates du passé,
le psychanalyste lui aussi creuse les différentes couches de l'inconscient.
Pompéi dans la nouvelle de Jensen est alors la représentation,
l'image de cet inconscient à découvrir.
Comme il le dit :
[Lecture de la citation par Clothilde]
L'analogie est subtile, tentante, voire belle et poétique
mais encore faut-il adhérer au travail de Freud et au travail du psychanalyste.
Mais le fait de savoir si Freud a raison ou non importe peu dans notre cas parce que ce qui compte c'est surtout de voir
que Pompéi a une aura si grande qu'on estime qu'elle peut incarner jusqu'à l'inconscient lui-même,
exactement comme le fait Freud,
et en quelque sorte qu'elle peut incarner ce qu'il y a de plus profond à l'intérieur de l'homme.
[Musique, choeur féminin]
Ce dernier exemple montre bien comment Pompéi pour de nombreux auteurs s'est présenté comme un petit défi,
un objet de fantasme assez exceptionnel capable de représenter des éléments mythiques, abstraits ou encore mystiques.
Freud finalement choisit de représenter l'intérieur de notre psyché comme une ville que la cendre aurait recouverte puis qu'on aurait redécouverte petit à petit.
Théophile Gautier y voit le lieu d'une rencontre possible entre les âmes et les époques
tandis que Mme de Staël médite sur la puissance d'un lieu qui rapproche de nous un passé censé être déjà mort.
Toutes ces approches révèlent comment Pompéi est devenu un objet d'art à part entière, un petit mythe que l'on peut décliner différemment,
même si cette ville est restée dans les imaginaires un haut lieu spirituel.
Aller à Pompéi c'est alors plus que voir des ruines
c'est chercher à faire l'expérience d'un passé qu'on rêve à portée de main.
Il serait possible d'aborder encore plus de textes tant ils sont nombreux à essayer d'écrire Pompéi, de s'approprier les lieux, voire d'essayer de les comprendre.
Pompéi fait partie de tout cet imaginaire antique qui suscite la rêverie car l'Antiquité, au delà, questionne sans cesse le rapport que nous entretenons
avec notre passé.
L'écriture semble le lieu idéal pour déployer ces rêveries et Pompéi en est le parfait exemple.
Pompéi, source de rêves infinis.
Ou comme le dit si joliment Claude Aziza :
[Générique de fin - Musique épique]